salut les épicuriens les épis curieux un
petit barbecue ça vous dit il y a des
brochettes de la viande du poisson des
saucisses des merguez des fruits et des
légumes les steak de soja même des
mouches et des guêpes mais au fait le
barbecue est ce vraiment bon pour la
santé certains en doutent on en parle
tout de suite croyez moi ça va chauffer
ben moi je suis prêt
[Musique]
vous l'avez peut-être déjà entendu dire
barbecue viendrait d'une vieille
expression française
barbecue barback eux il s'agit d'une
pratique moyenâgeuse qui consistait à
embrocher une chaise pour la faire cuire
à la broche au dessus des braises la
broche et est enfilé de la barbe à la
queue et les anglais qui prononçait mal
le français aurait transformé barba que
en bande ku sauf que non c'est une
légende légende un peu fumeuse quand
même en réalité le mot barbecue
viendrait de la wac est la langue des
tainos un ancien peuple amérindien qui
vivaient dans les caraïbes à la fin du
xvème siècle lorsque les espagnols
colonisent la région muse y découvre un
nouveau mode de cuisson des branchages
qui servent de support à la viande
placer au dessus des braises dernière
l'appel ou barbacoa les espagnols conte
qui adore un peu tiré par les cheveux
peut-être mais la méthode est ingénieuse
la viande est surélevé ce qui évite
qu'elles sont dévorés par les animaux en
prime la fumée tient les insectes à
distance ce qui permet une meilleure
conservation de la viande importée en
europe et adoptée par les anglais se
barbacoa serait devenu avec le temps et
avec l'accent le barbecue
au 19e siècle il envahit l'amérique
grâce à la conquête de l'ouest il permet
aux migrants de se nourrir en plein air
durant leur long périple vers la
californie mais il faut attendre la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale pour que
le barbecue entre dans les foyers
américains dans les années 1950 il
devient même l'un des symboles de
l'american way of life et il finit par
envahir le monde et pas que les aires de
pique nique le livre des records
également comme une entreprise
américaine qui détient la palme du
barbecue le plus cher du monde environ
cent cinquante mille euros il faut dire
que ce magnifique objet plaqué or depuis
15 ans deux pays se disputent par
ailleurs le record du plus grand
barbecue du monde il s'agit de la
cantine et de son voisin l'uruguay
tenant du titre depuis 2010 est amina ce
une petite ville du sud du pays plus de
200 personnes ont désossé et placés sur
les grilles les morceaux d'une centaine
de vaches au total à près de 16 tonnes
de viande est la performance a nécessité
60 tonnes de bois et une centaine de
cuisinier qui se sont relayés pendant 14
heures pour surveiller la cuisson
à mon avis les argentins n'ont pas dit
leur dernier mot il faut dire que là-bas
on ne plaisante pas non pas avec le
barbecue mais las à dos et nous
tu crois qu'on plaisante en france on
détient pas de record mais le bar bugs
comme on dit c'est aussi du sérieux plus
de 60% des foyers en sont équipés
d'ailleurs chaque année au mois de
septembre se déroule aux
saintes-maries-de-la-mer le championnat
de france de barbecue de 80 équipes
viennent de toute la france pour se
disputer le titre du barbecue le plus
succulent il y en a pour tous les goûts
viandes poissons fruits légumes plats de
résistance et dessert 1 on s'inscrit je
suis chaud comme la braise mais
auparavant j'ai encore quelques infos
sur le grill on l'a dit le barbecue est
une méthode depuis son astucieuse
découverte chez les indiens d'amérique
mais ils n'ont pas inventé
cette méthode de cuisson est beaucoup
plus ancienne elle date de la
préhistoire les plus vieilles traces
sont estimées à 1,5 million d'années
elles ont été identifiées en 2019 sur un
site archéologique de la région de kobe
fera au kenya a découverte de ce
barbecue préhistorique a bouleversé nos
connaissances elle a permis de repousser
d'un million d'années les premières
traces d'usagé contrôlée du feu par les
hommes jusque là on estimait que notre
lointain cousin homo erectus avait
commencé à maîtriser le feu il y a cinq
cent mille ans
et ça change quoi eh bien ça renforce
l'hypothèse que l' usage du barbecue a
eu une influence majeure sur l'évolution
biologique du genre homo le recours à la
cuisse ont en effet permis de rendre la
viande plus tendres cela intensité est
la mastication et donc la digestion des
aliments le corps d'hommes - efforts
pour digérer il a pu utiliser cette
énergie qu au profit de nouvelles
compétences le barbecue aurait également
entraîné une modification du régime
alimentaire de nos ancêtres il leur a
permis de consommer certains légumes
très difficile à digérer cru comme le
blé l'orge les racines les tubercules
cette nouvelle richesse alimentaires
auraient favorisé l'évolution du cerveau
des hominidés le barbecue nous a rendu
intelligent il a fait mieux que ça il a
contribué à l'augmentation de notre
espérance de vie cuire la viande a
permis d'éliminer des parasites qui est
des vecteurs de maladies mortelles bon
c'est pas tout je commence à avoir une
petite faim
[Musique]
ça chauffe bien quand on parle de
barbecue une question revient souvent
est ce dangereux pour notre santé en
effet la cuisson au grill favoriserait
l'apparition de certains cancers cette
crainte n'est pas injustifiée les vous
allez le voir utiliser correctement ce
mode de cuisson ne présente aucun risque
alors c'est vrai plusieurs études ont
démontré que lorsque la viande et le
poisson sont cuits à feu vif ils
produisent de nouveaux composés
chimiques sous forme de fumée notamment
il s'agit de yamine hétérocycliques hc a
aidé les hydrocarbures aromatiques
polycycliques
h à b alors là il m'a perdue dit comme
ça c'est un peu compliqué ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que ces substances sont
potentiellement cancérogènes en cas
d'ingestion ou d'inhalation pour vous
donner une idée on les retrouve
également dans la fumée de cigarette
mais rassurez-vous en respectant
certaines règles de cuisson on peut
facilement y minimiser les risques
première précaution à prendre vos
aliments doivent être placés à la bonne
hauteur là par exemple la grille est
trop basse trop proche des braises je
vais là réhaussé elle doit au minimum se
trouvait à 10 cm des braises
de cette manière la viande ne sera
jamais en contact avec les flammes ce
sont elles qui carbonisent la nourriture
consommée trop fréquemment ou sur une
longue période les aliments carbonisé
augmente sensiblement les risques de
cancer et bien sûr n'hésitez pas à
cuisiner poisson des légumes ou des
fruits au barbecue ils sont excellents
puis sur la brèche
[Musique]
je me suis brûlé ah oui le feu ça brûle
c'est le plus grand danger avec le
barbecue c'est même un classique de
l'été environ 200 brûlures graves sont
recensés chaque année par le ministère
de la santé il fait chaud on est torse
nu un moment d'inattention et hop c'est
l'accident bête à l'eau les pompiers je
vous rassure est la plupart des brûlures
sont superficielles il convient
toutefois de respecter quelques
consignes n'utilisez jamais d'alcool à
brûler pour démarrer votre feu les
projections d'alcool enflammé sont
responsables de la plupart des accidents
préférez un allume feu traditionnelles
et y est également toujours à portée de
main de l'eau et du sable pour éteindre
le feu si nécessaire et surtout éloignez
les enfants du barbecue ils représentent
15% des victimes à cause de leur petite
taille ils sont à peu près à la hauteur
du feu bon et quand est ce qu'on mange
parce que les bonnes paroles 1 ça
nourrit pas ça va il n'y a pas le feu à
ce propos on n'allume pas un barbecue
n'importe où
les communes et les départements les
interdisant les zones boisées
heureusement alors le plus sûr me direz
vous c'est installer sur son balcon mou
sur sa terrasse sauf que ce n'est pas
aussi simple le règlement intérieur de
votre copropriété peut l'interdire idem
pour le jardin en période de sécheresse
certaines municipalités interdisent les
barbecues a arrêté municipal menon mais
alors il nous reste quoi les parcs
publics c'est la dernière chose à faire
à paris par exemple il est formellement
interdit d'allumer un feu dans un lieu
public vous vous exposeriez à une amende
qui peut aller jusqu'à 127 euros ça fait
cher la saucisse est chez moi j'ai
vérifié si autorisée bon on sait un
petit barbecue tu viens je teste les 70
à
une bonne petite brochette et voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui n'oubliez
pas l'essentiel cet été c'est de vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait votre
barbecue n'en sera que meilleur et puis
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à liker ça me fera chaud que bon il
est temps de nous quitter je vous laisse
méditer sur cette citation de coluche le
barbecue en gros c'est un appareil qui
permet de manger des saucisses
pratiquement cru mais à mettre le bout
des doigts bien cuit
[Musique]